all right guys my uh nightwing shirt's a
little bit dirty but that's because i
had to pull it out of the word work for
this video today before going into that
john are you good you're good i'm good
i'm good all right good good got your
thing out of the way that you're doing
good everyone loves john yeah yeah all
right ladies and gentlemen we are gonna
watch today the jason todd robin teaser
trailer from high top films we have to
do a live stream in a little bit but
when this came out and i was like well
we definitely gotta cover this too so
this is from high top films and i i
introduced john to high top films um
well over a year ago he has one of those
channels where whenever he's got a video
essay up i watch those essays pretty
much religiously i disagree with the guy
so much at the time but he's such a
wonderful communicator so articulate so
much passion even a lot of the times the
ones i'm like no i actually love this
one and he doesn't i can still find
things i'm like but i didn't see that
and you write about that
sometimes you can open my eyes if
there's any video essay out there who
can be persuasive to me it's it's his
videos i love what he does he's a
massive dc fan massive batman robin fan
batman and robin that's his favorite one
of them all so maybe you don't trust him
that's not his favorite one but no like
this project is extremely passionate for
him he's been working on it for such a
long time obviously an aspiring
filmmaker and it really resonates in the
way he talks about film in general
there's an indiegogo project out there
available he didn't ask me to plug it
i'm just telling you guys this indiegogo
project still going around for this and
if you saw the teaser trailer from a few
months ago you'll see that passion is on
display and uh now we got another minute
teaser wanted to check it out show
support link in the description box and
pin common for you know indiegogo and
his channel let's see what's in store
[Music]
love the text
[Music]
she's gone
now that ain't rare as you know
but i gotta be real with you kid
i don't think she's coming back this
time
you know why kid
the why is the one thing i've been
trying to teach you
the one thing you have to remember
you and me
we're [ __ ]
we're always gonna be [ __ ]
you
you were born [ __ ]
you're on your own now kid
ain't nobody now
nobody back then
nobody
is
gonna care
about
you
awesome it's great text yeah all right
ej
it's time for bed
i love that just tone and atmosphere and
a tease of uh of what's to come she did
come back she didn't come for the
voiceover
the way this is all being communicated
right now is so beautiful and elegant
and like i love the haunting atmosphere
that it provides it was like jason todd
is not like a character that i uh obsess
over necessarily but he is one that is
fascinating because you know in his
original run he was voted to get killed
off
death in the family but when he was
brought back this is obviously more of
what i imagine the interpretation is
that uh they're going for with this film
because like i said i actually don't
really i haven't really been following
like up to date necessarily the
specifics on what this film is going to
be covering
but this seems to be more in tune with
you know the the criminal orphan on the
streets though the one who took uh try
stealing batman's tires like
that one who eventually batman adopted
and wanted to try to keep his rage under
control and so you get all that on
display here all that angst and
animosity and that hurt that sorrow that
loss
of course with that like reflective red
lighting that evokes gotham but also
passion and blood i i really love um
what's being told so far like the other
teaser trailer showed us a little bit
more but this time we got to get a taste
of the costume and sort of feeling like
the robin and the jason todd is almost
like a split personality of sorts or one
where he
of the darkness that he embodies
as robin of like this is the like in
some ways it feels like this is the
version of robin that batman fears that
jason todd will become
just this violent menace this one who
wants to take out all that rage on
criminals so yeah while i'm not the most
knowledgeable about jason todd i'm
definitely familiar with the character
uh i'm liking what we're doing here
because i think the thing with uh high
top films that i i think we can trust
that alex would do
is keep it more character study focused
than pulpy action or looking like a
comic book like while it will have that
i imagine what we're really going to be
getting is something that feels very uh
deep and introspective
and moody oh yeah it's gotta have all
the sort of gusto of one of alex's
actual written monologues but just
translated into film form and i'm really
excited to see something like this
because yeah coming from somebody who i
know mostly from the video essays that
you've shown me and that i've been since
this is clearly somebody with tons of
passion who has studied film a lot so i
feel like the stakes are high when you
move into you know like releasing your
own narrative work in that sense but i
also believe that there is just a an
immense uh potential to show yeah that
level of understanding of a character
and that level of love and care for a
character in a smaller package like a
short film and yeah i loved the
simplicity of this you've got the red
lighting which easily communicates rage
and easily works with you know the
recent
you know batman movie and things like
that not that they're necessarily going
for it but yeah this whole thing was
like seething to me was just the word i
kept coming back to is like you keep
cutting between the orphan and robin and
seeing how one looks so kind of forlorn
and so uh you know cold and saddened in
in just this pelting rain and the other
looks so formidable and so you know
again seething in a way where he's not
even moving he's just looking at you but
i can already feel that tension of like
i can tell this guy wants to snap this
guy wants to beat down some people in
the name of quote justice you know like
that ride that line between justice and
rage
and you know the voice over i thought
was a nice touch and having the mom's
voice come in a little bit at the end
just to tease that family tension that
you know like twisted harsh upbringing
that the different iterations of jason
todd's story includes uh yeah this this
again for such a simple teaser that's
built on just one zoom intercutting
between two people or two you know
different visages of the same guy i
thought really communicated nicely
what might be in the store and it got me
really excited to see the full thing
yeah it's beautiful it's elegant
and uh yeah guys deliberate please show
your support uh for this and if you
haven't if you want to know like how how
much of if you haven't seen any high top
films
you know guys
he's definitely has been the kindness of
the mcu so but we're talking dc right
now so go check out some of his videos
about some dc films and you'll see like
very few can articulate as well as this
gentleman right here and also the
editing behind the videos too like
beyond just the scripting like the
editing is phenomenal yeah and he even
likes to in you know implement uh little
filmmaking inserts of his own into it
more than just pulling footage you know
and i know this video is barely edited
right now uh because we have to rush to
do a live stream but i i
just wanted to go here and show some
support so thank you guys for being here
and uh we will talk to you all soon
subscribe to high top films